[Musique]
dont les contrées aussi lointaines de la
mauricie à une trentaine de kilomètres
de la ville de la tuque sur un
magnifique plan d'eau du nom de dumoulin
où se situe la pourvoirie du même nom
son encontre une pêcheuse est un pécheur
qui espère capturer est l'une des belles
espèces de poissons d'eau douce que l'on
peut retrouver dans les milliers de lacs
des rivières du canada
on est sur un des nombreux des milliers
l'acquis du québec est réelle richesse
mais il y adhérer richesse parce que
c'est le fait de prélever quelque chose
le tpiy de cuisine et de pics et ça ça
peut ça je peux quand notre apparaît
aujourd'hui d'abord ça se peut tout est
relatif on va quand même d'un petit peu
d'efforts mais à la fin c'est que le
terroir nous donne tellement de choses
le téléthon l'été c'est la pêche
l'automne ça peut être la chasse la
cueillette vie c'est d'aller les
chercher puis il ya en même temps de
relaxer était d'enlever un petit peu
tout s'est tu
cette pression de la vie quotidienne
regarde là on est là on est tous bien
tout est disponible et amène tes enfants
on jette un hameçon un bouchon puis tout
va bien avec un morceau de verre
n'importe quoi ça peut être gratuit on
peut aller pêcher justement à 1000
pièces par jour si on veut on peut
pêcher dans le fleuve de l'esturgeon
c'est complètement gratuit le soir c'est
avec une petite bière sur le quai ça ça
va super bien
sipa une pêche commerciale on n'exploite
pas est ce qu'ils me donnent une
mauvaise chose
tant et aussi longtemps la tique on
pourra pas avoir accès à ça dans nos
restaurants
mais on pourra pas servir le vrai
terroir puis si c'est un petit peu le
même discours que j'ai par rapport à la
chasse tant qu'on servira pas de
l'orignal ou du chevreuil ou n'importe
quoi mais est-ce qu'on va vraiment
servir le jeu par le terroir québécois
c'est je pense pas il n'y a pas de
danger qu'on se mette à exploiter la
richesse de nos lacs et puis que tout le
monde vienne vampiriser cette richesse
mais c'est pas infinies mais je pense
que on a sûrement des moyens des options
loti pour le faire mais une
commercialisation de ce qui serait quand
même assez assez réduite je comprends
que la ressource n'est pas inépuisable
ça je sais je suis pas je suis pas fou à
temps plein c'est ça je le comprends
mais il ya sûrement des moyennes je veux
dire on a des tags pour du homard tu
sais tu marches du homard ça c'est ça
vient de chez nous tu marche du crabe il
vient de chez nous aussi mais tu marches
pas notre mouchetés par exemple à -
keystone m beaucoup d'amateurs de pêche
qui savent pas nécessairement quoi faire
avec leurs primes devraient tout à fait
chez nous on donne des trucs pour bain
cuisine les prépare les uns sortante
appauvri comme ça quand arrive chez vous
c'est prêt tu mets ça sur des pattes ça
fonctionne puis faut juste tintamarre
j'ai du pain gazut ce n'est pas qu'à moi
c'est aussi même magie du brochet la
même si c'est planar est là
juste au québec les lacs et les rivières
abrite pas moins de 118 espèces de
poissons dont la perchaude le doré et
l'achigan le brochet et bien sûr la
truite mouchetée en 2019 plus de 700000
permis de pêche sportive ont été
délivrés dans cette seule province
[Musique]
bon mais faute d'avoir risqué parce
qu'ils sont qu'est ce qu'on fait avec le
brochet pêché ce matin par nos hôtes
on va faire la miche oui on a préparé un
feu avec la bresse puis on va se
préparer pour mettre sur la broche
tranquillement le plus simplement
possible
la beauté de la chose le sait c'est que
le poisson et frais avec il n'y a pas
besoin de grand chose tout fait pour ça
goûte bon c'est ça fera du sel ça prend
les oignons puis alors ça tue mais ce
que tu veux dans c'est ça qui est super
important que ça nous prend une belle
broche et l'âne aux hôtes ils ont été
magiques c'est toujours comme ça c'est
vraiment juste le thé pour parfumer
l'intérieur je préfère la même chose à
la maison leur moi j'aime quelqu'un qui
aurait attrapé du pressentiment n'a pas
la pression belle-fille c'est parce que
sinon c'est un petit peu moi c'est ça la
plus grosse difficulté c'est quand la
plus grosse difficulté c'est cela
puis le temps de cuisson pour un poisson
comme ça ça marche ça va des ça va
dépendre c'est toujours pareil quand on
fait des livres ou quand on fait des
recettes c'est on nous impose de mettre
un temps mais ça dépend la taille dit en
passant ce n'est pas en intensité ton
feu la hauteur à laquelle vivait retiré
à la fin c'est je pense le gros bon sens
joue souvent sur on va le savoir faut se
faire confiance
c'est frais ça regarde on a juste
mais là c'est juste un prétexte parce
que la regarde on regarde le poisson en
cuir le site je le regarderai une cure
dans ton four comme sa chose non mais
ici on dit juste c'est un bon cela c'est
pire
c'est pas beau la vie romana
ça c'est un quart du poisson qu'on à fos
maraîchers du fauve reporting statham et
empêcher tout s'est tu pêches tu marches
sa grille est directement quand on
commençait le brochet présentement mais
quand tu le ramène chez toi battitta
passe à l'étape à l'environnement n'a
pas fait que tu les un congélateur puis
un jour tu es dans nos champs fait que
c'est en réfléchissant aux religieux s'y
marient pourquoi l'at il tue le préparer
pas mettant en étant dans son chalet
tranquille c'est le sort tu les prépas
puis quand tu les ramènent elles sont
déjà prêtes qu'après sa basse et eu les
mots congélateur mais tu peux les sortir
quand on a besoin mais c'est déjà cuit
c'est déjà près vide et déjà déjà facile
parce que ces sas avec n'importe quelle
espèce ou presque lille tourne la truite
mouchetée mulak étaient tous là ça
marche
après ça les poids semble en fait c'est
moi j'irai peut-être plus comme comme
ils font sur la côte-nord savez le
flétan epson c'est plus un du vinaigre
c'est une marina réintégrer ou salés ou
mais sa marge en 2010 tu le fais ça va
tu peux te faire des rillettes tu peux
mettre sa main des pas tu me sens de ce
que tu veux et surtout matt et moi je
donne une recette entre guillemets mais
têtu mais ce que tu voudras
[Musique]
mais ton titre même si quand est qu'à sa
soeur propre la saveur sécu et c'est
pour ça aussi le petit aleph pas des
écailles on enlève rien on n'avait pas
les écueils
la pauvre faire comme un espèce de
papier d'admirer ces tours en ce moment
je peux la peau non ça sent bon en tout
cas juste à le défaire il regarde tes
fait des beaux des bouts de choc
on peut même si j'essaie directement
avec les doigts la bouche est parfaite
et puissant est parfaite aussi sait
jamais le temps de cuisson qu autant que
c'est la température de cuisson
tu vois comme là on se prend pas la tête
c'est là on s'attend pas à ce qu'ils
soient cuits parfaitement s'attend pas à
ce qu'ils soient en satin juste un match
du poids sans merci des venus à la pêche
avec n'hésitez pas merci même si on n'a
pas de prix écoute en mode était à la
pêche on a essayé c'est pas faute
d'avoir essayé savait cuisiner mais on
essaye
le lendemain par un beau matin
ensoleillé la pêche le seul à bord de
son embarcation tente à nouveau sa
chance
et surprise voilà une belle ombles de
fontaine
de plus deux kilos en premier point
simple